what's up y'all it's your boy brandon
williams thanks for joining us on
another episode of streets of style
brought to you by bleacher reporter tiso
today we got my guy davion mitchell
we're gonna talk to him about his tunnel
style his favorite watch and then find
one of sacramento's best dressed fans
and blessing with their very own tiso
watch
yo
what's up b
how you doing it's been a minute it's
wait a minute bro wait a minute oh man
i've been in sacramento in a while man
but i'm here you're fresh let's talk
about the the the gear real quick you
know i got to get to fit check okay so
first of all are these a go-to for you
you got the travis's on i know you're a
nike guy so yeah usually when i um when
i go out it's either
travis's or some type of dunk so yeah
are you a big hypebeaster or you like
more luxury because you got both on the
day yeah i definitely got both of them
but i feel like dunks are like more
classic yeah for short like simple
colors i'm not really i don't want to be
like i don't really want to stand out
yeah kind of just you know easy yeah
what's the thing in the tunnel that you
think is your go-to as far as like if i
if i'm going to a game i gotta have this
on
this right here i gotta have this on me
so what do you call that i have my own
name for it i'll give it to you what is
it it's called a fly finisher oh i like
that okay so this is a finisher my
accessory game is also a finisher i see
you got a all black blacked out t-cell
super sport that's fire yeah this is
pretty clean they actually go with the
fit too that's what i'm saying so i
that's all i know the accessories got to
be a big part of you so we did the fit
check
all boxes check i actually do a lot of
that's like people watching that's one
of my favorite things to do for a number
of reasons today we're actually gonna go
do a little people watching ourselves
we're gonna find one of sacramento's
best dressed i'm gonna pick out the
person with the best style okay i'm
gonna have you surprise them after we
get done talking with their very own
t-cell watch oh i'm rolling with you
with that yeah let's go do it bro
yeah dude you know so for me style is
everything but um
i'm influenced by like not just like
people watching you know but
but a lot of
what guys do in the league you know what
i mean is there a lot is there a lot of
inspiration you take from other guys in
the league like i said before guys on my
team like tyreese halliburton guys i
actually see yeah i mean because i don't
really just look on like lee fitz and
right and just go from style from towers
like if i see it it's like oh
okay let me see what i can do what my
version of that is right right now
listen we came out here to try to find
somebody with you know fresh style
i don't really see nobody right now i'm
looking you see anybody um
nah i really don't
this might be a little tough but i i i
have faith so let's just keep on walking
i think let's try down here okay
hey y'all i think i see somebody yeah
but like what you think it's like yeah
he's definitely one he's the one he's
going anymore
what up man
what's good bro brandon brandon ryan
yeah he's my guy right here you might
know him so bro how are you how are you
doing i'm just dressed to impress
just want to come talk to you a little
bit about style obviously davion you
know nba best one of the best stressed
in the league yeah and you know we see
you here we talked a little bit about
what creates a great outfit who inspires
us like what about you how are you
inspired does nba style inspire you a
little bit yeah for sure i mean i'm
always looking at league fits and uh you
know i see some really great fits on
there i think uh jordan clarkson for
sure is number one oh dortmund jc who
was the same jake was talking about
you got a dope jacket here dope pants
like
how do you start off your look uh i just
start off with statement pieces and once
i find that statement piece i kind of
work work my way around that you know
build the outfit around that this outfit
has everything you would need in a look
but
davion what does it need to complete you
need one finisher you need a finisher
and on behalf of tiso we're gonna give
you a finisher it's a super sporty so
watch
man my man davion
look at that oh snap
it's a matte black finish definitely go
with your fit goes with your fit really
understated piece but also heavy on the
details it's a chronograph watch so it
has multiple movements and it's
everything you need from
date night to office day yeah to
spending the parts first yeah man thank
you man for real thank you no problem
bro
you